eight strikeouts away from tying cyong
for 22nd place
on the all-time major league baseball
strikeout list
[Applause]
look outside there might be company
coming max's first of the night taylor
widener 26 year old reinhander a win
over the padres a no decision against
the reds so far
there's the slider up he strikes out
turner to get us started
josh van mater set to lead off the
second in washington
how about three change-ups in a row from
max scherzer
strikeout number two
swinging on this on the fastball
so that's 2801
five more
to tie
side
here's castro who's 10 for 39
starting his season here's the pitch
swinging a fly ball shallow right
slicing toward the line calhoun on the
run can't get their lands fair harrison
had a hold a slide into foul ground for
calhoun losing his footing two on two
outrunners on the corners here's robles
who's batting eight tonight and after
the long look the pitch is grounded
sharply down to third escobar's got it
throws the first for the elemental and
the hunting hearted
swing gonna miss
number four
here's trey turner
it's a great at-bat so an 0-2 walk for
trey turner and then that's in business
with some speed on the bases here in the
third and here comes juan soto
on the ground smothered by cabrera
widener hustles over there
and turner's in at third out number two
only survive that
cold calhoun two three four for the
d-backs
swing and i missed
number five for mack sure stalking
0-2
[Music]
he's just blowing people away upstairs
downstairs sideways next surgery in this
game has 11 outs six of them on strikes
every one of them swinging
back to back walks after he'd set down
13 straight
and now it's taylor whitener two on it
two out
tailing fastball number seven for
scherzer
one
to tie
cy young when he next takes them out
yeah good wheels at second and one of
your best hitters up in the scoreless
game in the fifth inning one two
center field le castro at the warning
track drifting back to the wall and he's
got just enough room
five zeroes on the board for taylor
whitener castro for two up there to
start the sixth
the castro there's the base hit into
left
making an eight-game hitting streak for
lacaster that's their first hit since
cole calhoun singled as the second
batter of the ball game
now with two outs we'll see if lo castro
looks to be more aggressive here
and try to get the scoring position with
david peralta at the play to strike out
on a pop-up in his two times up
out into center
victor robles is there
max scherzer six scoreless
on only two hits
soto oh for two so far
juan soto just spits on it goes to first
lead off man aboard
to start the indian and now josh bell at
the plate
chase to highland up and away widener
gets out number one
red hot josh harrison this guy
has been a hit machine
deep to center look castro's there
another zero on the board once again
taylor widener works out of trouble
and we're still scoreless
[Music]
seven punch-outs for max one to tai sai
swing and a mess
cy young meet mr scherzer
2
806
strikeouts
here's the wind up in the 1-2 to escobar
swinging a miss he struck him out on a
94 mile per hour fastball
they're going to toss that baseball out
of play he is now past cy young career
strikeout 2
807
22nd alone on the all-time strikeout
list
and here is carson kelly
and for max scherzer
his 99th
10 strikeout game
the k's and the numbers just keep on
coming and now the left-handed swinging
paving smith first baseman outfielder to
be the pinch hitter
and he hits it out to left center victor
robles after it yes
and down he goes
due down what a catch
and he would slice it away from victor
robles and watch
the route he takes here but see the ball
slice
and carry
and he knew the fence was approaching
and once he caught it he just kind of
hit the deck because he reached as far
as he could
the outstretched glove across his body
swaying and a miss
a fist pump
from daniel hudson he did everything but
throw his glove
and it's a one two three top of the
eight we got a ball game they're into it
aren't they
max scherzer
bumping chests in the dugout now daniel
hudson showing postseason emotion on the
mound after the strikeout you got to
love this don't you
and now as jubal cabrera will turn
and hit from the right side
breaking ball
how well placed a slide a throw josh
harrison
both sides of the baseball
red hot with the bat and a brilliant
play up the middle
[Applause]
bottom of the ninth inning but
left-hander alex young stays in there
and kyle schwarber will come up
there it goes
game winner
c
u
later
way up there the second deck
it's a walk-off game-winning home run
for kyle schwarber
his first home run as a national
brings the house down
and they mob him at home plates
a curly w is in the books
kyle schwarber with a tape measure home
run
and the nationals have beaten the
diamondbacks
one
to nothing
[Applause]